>> SEAN: A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE", AMERICAN
CROSSROADS.
TONIGHT SPECIAL IS GOING TO
ADDRESS ISSUES IN OUR POLITICS
AND CULTURE THAT ARE DIVIDING
AMERICA RIGHT INTO.
IN WHAT WE CAN DO TO REMEDY THIS
.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S DECISION TO GIVE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR THE
TWO DECLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
RELATED TO THE 2016 CAMPAIGN
SURVEILLANCE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST AMERICANS
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT HAS THEIR BEST
INTEREST AT HEART ALWAYS.
AND WHEN IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
SOMEONE IN THE UPPER ECHELON OF
THE DOJ AND FBI, NCA AND OTHER
INTEL ORGANIZATIONS MAY HAVE HA
THEIR THUMB ON THE POLITICAL
SCALE, A LOT OF AMERICANS WERE
RIGHTLY OUTRAGED.
THAT IS WHY IT IS SO STANDING T
SEE DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS SWOR
TO UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTION FIGH
SO HARD TO CONCEAL PRESENT
THREATS TO A.
TAKE ADAM SCHIFF, HE CALLED
TRUMP'S DECISION TO GIVE THE
PUBLIC MORE INFORMATION
UN-AMERICAN.
IF WE CAN'T EVEN AGREE UPON
BASIC SET OF STANDARDS UNDER
WHICH THESE POWERFUL
ORGANIZATIONS CAN ACT,
ESPECIALLY IN RELATION TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEN WE ARE
INDEED AT A CROSSROADS.
NOW TRUMP ADDRESSED THIS ISSUE
FROM THE OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE
HOUSE THIS AFTERNOON.
LET'S WATCH.
>> ID CLASSIFIED EVERYTHING FOR
IT EVERYTHING THEY WANT I PUT I
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE WILL BE IN CHARGE OF IT.
I DON'T WANT THEM TO BE FOR ME
ANYBODY ELSE I JUST WANT HIM TO
BE FAIR.
WE ARE BEING TRANSPARENT.
WE ARE BEING ULTIMATELY
TRANSPARENT AND THAT'S WHAT IT'
ABOUT.
>> TRANSPARENCY IS TO BE A GOOD
WORD.
IT SUNSHINE, BUT APPARENTLY NOT
ONE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ADVOCATING FOR A.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION,
ATTORNEY AND MEMBER OF THE TRUM
2020 ADVISORY COUNCIL.
MEMBER OF THE CONSERVATIVE UNIO
AND SECRETARY OF STATE UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
GREAT TO SEE YOU ON A FRIDAY
NIGHT.
THE LEFT IS ACCUSING TRUMP OF
SOME GRAND COVER-UP.
WHY WOULD HE URGE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO DECLASSIFY ALL THIS
INFORMATION IF THERE WERE ALL
THESE NUGGETS AND BITS AND
PIECES THAT WERE GOING TO
INCRIMINATE HIM OR ANYONE IN HI
CAMPAIGN.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT TO QUESTION PER
TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE FOR EXAMPLE AN UN-
REDUCTION OF THE MOLAR REPORT.
IF WE WANT TRANSPARENCY LET'S
GET IT ALL OUT THERE.
TO HAVE IT IN ONE DIRECTION TO
UNMASK AMERICAN SPIES, THOSE
HELPING THE UNITED STATES
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY, GEARS I
COMPETING THINGS.
WE CAN UNREDACTED THE VERY FEW
NOT VERY MUCH OF THE THAT IS NO
AVAILABLE ESPECIALLY TO MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS WHO CAN GO READ IT
AND READ IT ALMOST IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
THEM,  BUT THAT IS PROBABLY VER
SENSITIVE SOURCING INFORMATION
AND METHODOLOGY,  BUT THIS IS
KIND OF WILD.
I FIND THIS TO BE WEIRD BECAUSE
I REMEMBER THE DEMOCRATS THERE
LIKE YOU GOT TO GET THE MAN
DEMANDS GOING TO KEEP THE INFO
FOR US THE FBI IS GOING TO HURT
THE REGULAR PEOPLE AND NOW THAT
SHE WAS ON THE OTHER FOOT, NOW
THEY'RE BIG DEFENDERS OF THE
SPINE AGENCIES REGARDLESS OF HO
MUCH POWER THEY HAVE.
>> I THINK YOU STARTED OFF
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE TRIED TO
HEAL THE RIFT.
YOU HEAL THE RIFT BY EXPOSING
WHAT HAPPENED UNDER THE OBAMA
BIDEN, AT THE END OF THEIR TERM
WHAT WAS DONE AGAINST THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS WHY DID THE
LET LOOSE THE FBI AND OTHER
AGENCIES TO GO OVER AFTER THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
IF THEY HAVE GOOD ANSWERS, THEN
LET'S MOVE BEYOND THIS.
I THINK THAT THAT IS THE KEY IN
ALL OF THIS BUT SOMEHOW WE
SKIPPED OVER THE OBAMA
WRONGDOING AND MOVED RIGHT TO
THE PHOTO DRUM CRIMES AND WE
HAVE BEEN STUCK ON THIS RUSSIA
COLLUSION THING.
IT'S TIME TO GET TO THE REAL
STORY.
>> JOHN KERRY IS ONE OF THE
PEOPLE MENTIONED IN SOME OF THE
STORIES ABOUT THE CIRCLE.
IT WAS A VERY TIGHT CIRCLE.
I WANT YOU TO CHIME IN HERE.
WE LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW THEY ME
AND HOW THEY DISCUSSED THE
ORIGINS OF THIS PROBE AND THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT RUSSIA AND THE
ELECTION.
ORIGINALLY AS BRENNAN, CLAPPER,
COMEY, AND I MISSING ONE.
SO IT'S VERY TIGHT AND THIN IT
INCLUDED VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN,
CAREY, AND ASH CARTER AND I
GUESS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WAS EVENTUALLY
BROUGHT INTO THE LOOP.
THIS IS FASCINATING.
WERE LEARNING HOW BRENNAN WOULD
BRIEF THE PRESIDENT AND KEEP TH
INFO OUT OF THE DAILY INTEL
BRIEFING.
THAT CAME OUT IN THE NEW YORK
TIMES TODAY.
I THINK WE'LL LEARN MORE ABOUT
THAT VERY INTERESTING DOUBLE
CONE OF SILENCE PURKEY
ABSOLUTELY.
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS WERE
GETTING REMINDED ABOUT RIGHT NO
IS THE FACT THAT BRITISH
INTELLIGENCE TO THE OBAMA
MINISTRATION IN 2015 ABOUT
ALLEGED HACKING BY THE RUSSIANS
BY THE DNC,  BUT THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT UNTIL VERY
LATE IN THE GAME AND UNTIL IT
WAS CLEAR THAT THEY HAD LOST
THAT ELECTION.
THEN EVERYTHING FELL INTO PLACE
VERY QUICKLY.
SO WHAT NANCY BELOW SEA AND HER
COLLEAGUES ARE DOING TODAY IS
GAS LIGHTING THE AMERICAN PEOPL
BY CALLING THE EXPOSURE OF A
COVER-UP AND OF A PLOT A
COVER-UP ITSELF.
THE LANGUAGE HAS NO MEANING WIT
THESE PEOPLE.
THIS IS KIND OF A DOUBLESPEAK
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
AT THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT TO DELEGATE THIS
AUTHORITY TO SOMEBODY WITH A
LONG HISTORY OF KNOWING HOW TO
CONFIDENTIAL.
>> THEY ARE TRASHING HIM.
BILL BARR IS NOW WHAT
HALLIBURTON WAS IN THE BUSH
YEARS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE THEY HAVE
TO HAVE THE EVILDOER PRAYED.
>> HE IS A PUNCHING BAG FOR THEM
.
IT'S BECOMING A LOGICAL MANEUVER
THAT, WELL, WE SHOULD UNMASK WE
SHOULD UNMASK AND WE SHOULD
REVEAL ALL THE SENSITIVE
INTELLIGENCE THAT OTHERS THOUGH
SHOULD BE REDACTED IN THE MOLAR
REPORT,  BUT THEN WE SHOULD NOT
ASK ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE
GOT THERE.
MOST AMERICANS CAN SEE THAT THE
PROCESS WAS.
>> WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
MEDIA ROLE IN THIS.
I THINK THAT IS PART OF WHY
PEOPLE CAN'T EVEN AGREE ON BASI
TERMINOLOGY.
RIGHT NOW THEY ARE FREAKING OUT.
THE AMERICAN MEDIA IS FREAKING
OUT OVER MORE TRANSPARENCY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT
.
>> DONALD IS OBVIOUSLY MELTING
DOWN.
THERE IS NO DOUBT HE'S UNHINGED
AS HE WAS ERRING THE MORE
INVESTIGATION.
>> HE HAS PROVEN HIMSELF IN MY
HUMBLE OPINION SORT OF THE TRAI
SEAL OF THE ADMINISTRATION
PAIRED.
>> THE IDEA OF GIVING BILL BARR
THE CLASSIFY ALL THE WITHIN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS REALL
UNPRECEDENTED.
>> UNPRECEDENTED.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HOW WAS THIS UNPRECEDENTED.
>> WITH THE DIRECTIVE THAT WAS
PUT OUT LAST NIGHT THIS IS
FOLLOWING A VERY CLEAR LEGAL
PATH AND THE GREAT THING ABOUT
BILL BARR IS HE'S BEEN THERE
BEFORE AND THE ONLY REASON HE
HAS EVEN MADE THE DECISION YET
THE ONLY REASON HE'S BEING
VILIFIED IS BECAUSE HE IS GOOD
AND THEY KNOW HE'S GOOD.
AND HE'S GOING TO MAKE SOUND
DECISIONS AND THEY KNOW THAT
WHEN THEY CALL HIM UP IN FRONT
OF THE SENATE AND THE HOUSE TO
ASK HIM QUESTIONS, HE JUST
PLAYED TEAMS WITH IMPAIRED HUMA
MULTITASKING PLAYS WITH
PAPERCLIPS WHILE HE ANSWERS
QUESTIONS.
HE'S READY FOR THIS.
>> THERE IS NO MATCH FOR BILL
BARR.
COULD GET THERE NOT GOOD ENOUGH
TO GET HIM TO ARISE.
>> EVEN MUELLER SAID HIMSELF
THAT BILL BARR AND THE WAY THAT
HE DESCRIBES THE REPORT IS
INACCURATE.
>> ON THE CALL THAT WAS
TRANSCRIBED IN THE NOTES IT SAI
HE DIDN'T SAY HE GOT IT WRONG I
THE CONCLUSION HE THOUGHT SOME
OF THE NUANCE AND TONALITY
DIDN'T CAPTURE THE MOMENT.
HE DIDN'T SAY HE GOT IT WRONG O
HIS CONCLUSION BECAUSE BILL BAR
ASKED THEM THAT HIM THAT IN THE
COLD.
>> WHERE IS MUELLER?
>> I HAVE TO ASK ABOUT THIS
IMPEACHMENT.
ON-AGAIN OFF-AGAIN IMPEACHMENT.
THE DEMOCRATS CANNOT MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT WHAT THEY WANT T
DO WITH IMPEACHMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE ARE SEEING MORE MEMBERS
THAT RECOGNIZE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTING IN A
LAWLESS FASHION ESSENTIALLY
HAVING OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE IS NO
OBSTRUCTING CONGRESS.
>> IT'S THE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, THESE COULD BE
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
>> COULD, WOULD, MIGHT BECOME A
MIGHT GET THEIR.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO BE
IMPEACHED.
>> I THINK THE IMPEACHMENT
QUESTION IS ONE WHERE WE ARE
WATCHING IT UNFOLD IN FRONT OF
US.
>> WHAT ARE THEY WAITING FOR
QUESTION MARK THEY HAVE THE
MUELLER REPORT.
>> I THINK CLEARLY DEMOCRATS
WANT TO HAVE HIM UP AND TESTIFY.
THEY WANT TO HAVE THE
TRANSPARENCY IS KEY ENDIF IT
SHOWS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
IMPEACHABLE THAN THAT'S WHAT
DEMOCRATS WILL DO.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO PUT WORDS I
HER MOUTH, BUT PELOSI IS
DEFINITELY PAIRED.
>> HARVEY CAMARA QUICK IMPEACH
OR NOT IMPEACHED.
THAT IS THE QUESTION ARE THE
DEMOCRATS GOING TO GO ANYWHERE
NEAR IMPEACHMENT THIS FACT ALL
THE TALK ABOUT.
>> A LOT OF MOCKERY HAS BEEN
MADE OVER THIS ISSUE,  BUT SHE
IS QUITE SMART AND SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO DO IT SHE'S BEEN PUSHED
TO DO IT HOWEVER BY HER UNRULY
LEFT-WING CAUCUS AND ULTIMATELY
IT WOULD PROBABLY BE OVER BERT
IS GOING TO BE POLITICAL
DISASTER FOR THE DEMOCRATS